the jurgen experience that's what take
them up the himalayas have you done that
yet [ __ ] that
that's not on the menu
you're like how do you know if you have
it in you if you could do it how do you
know
you need to do it to prove it i don't
need to do it to prove it i don't know
i'm not interested in it i'm not
interested in that himalayas that's what
rahm das used to call it yeah the
himalayas is that how you [ __ ] say
this
yeah if i used to have a joke about it
about the himalayas yeah about how
there's dead bodies on the way up there
and you're like
and like you have to have such
incredible arrogant because they don't
it's so cold that they have to leave the
dead bodies so as you're walking up this
trail to the top of this mountain hoping
to be one of the people that makes it
you get to look to the left and the
right of you
and there's dead bodies it's wild
there's dead bodies from the 30s
what yes and they're not decomposed
because it's super cold frozen solid
like a rock and you they look like
they're made out of plaster
they're white pale white frozen
you see their skin like their clothing
has been pushed away a little bit by
time and worn out and you could see part
of their skin
yeah there's people that they know who
the person is like it's a famous hiker
you can walk no i'm not bullshitting at
all and you could walk i got i was
obsessed with this for months i was
reading stories about hikers look at
this
these are hikers bodies
and they just leave that one on the far
left yep they just leave them there look
at that one look at his skin bro pick
him up no i don't think you can't
because the air is so thin it's so
dangerous that to bring that guy down
would risk people's lives because it's
so hard to get up there and they just
leave him up there
i think they've removed some of them
this [ __ ] makes me so angry yeah you
know what else infuriates me
i was watching a documentary about this
this guy that free climbing oh alex
honold i don't know everybody i've had
him on a few times
[ __ ] it makes me so [ __ ] mad because
i'm like what are you doing it's just
you know he's like and then i put my
finger in the crevice i don't have any
back it's like not only that sometimes
it gets tricky
sometimes it's like i have to lift my
foot up and get it to the spot or i'm
gonna die
i have to lift my foot up over here and
push off look at that what the [ __ ] yeah
this guy
wow what are you doing
just what that looks like is just bro
his little pants are falling down his
dick is going to pop he's got dick root
he's showing dick root
he's showing some dick room so he's in
good shape he should he looks great
super super super super nice guy
he's been on the podcast a few times i
think three times i really enjoy talking
to him so what's his what he just it
gets him excited to do this um he first
of all he loves being in nature and i
think there's this accomplishment thing
that comes with being able to climb
something
with
no ropes
because there's no
if
it's just must do must do for to live
you know you see people on those ropes
like sometimes they slip and they fall
off like would you have slipped if you
felt and fallen off if there was no rope
right right like these [ __ ] crazy
[ __ ]
climb is this the guy that got arrested
this is alex this is why oh dude oh
that's him too yeah look at him he's got
his little chalky hands oh my god he's
climbing a [ __ ] building he's so high
that's so crazy how old is this guy he
says climbs halfway up new jersey
skyscraper why half how does he get back
down i don't know what happens then do
you slide down my hands are so sweaty i
know i know i know i know i don't like
it again
it gives me diarrhea just like oh i
don't want to see this i know it's it
take it away wait wait but joe have you
seen the documentary
about the divers who rescue the children
trapped in the tie
no i haven't seen that tommy made me
watch it he's like you're gonna love it
it's very inspirational i don't like
children getting [ __ ] with ever
children are trapped inside of a [ __ ]
cave yeah they find divers who are like
hobbyist divers like a bunch just old
white guys like introvert
weirdos or cave divers because the
military can't hack it they don't know
how to get in and get these kids out
it's a fascinating story should i tell
you what happens
spoiler alerts okay i know i probably
should have said this before but okay
anyway
yo yo yo so these are the guys and they
find this group of like misfit dudes who
love cave diving and they can go into
these tiny little angles i mean look at
the it's all so narrow
and like i said the boys trapped they
got trapped in a storm and they were
there for like a month oh it's awful and
they had to devise a plan to get these
boys out
and oh my god can i tell you how they
did it sure
it's so crazy they consulted with this
anesthesiologist
and they put an apparatus on the boys
faces to put them under anesthesia
and then
and then the professional diver would
take them through the cave very
carefully out over like two or three
hours while this kid was under two or
three hours oh my god i mean like i'm
crying even just [ __ ] remembering it
oh my god it was horrible
look look this is the route so there's
the boys
this is insane so they had to find a way
to be able to carry
a kid
safely put a mask without the kid
freaking out yeah right because if the
kid freaks out it kicks up dust well i
had donald cerrone on my podcast and he
was cave diving with this guy and the
guy got his
his tube tangled his rope tangled and he
freaked out and spazzed out and he
filled the cabin up with silts and they
couldn't see anymore and he couldn't
figure out how to get out and see and he
was running out of air and he had to try
to it's the most riveting story i've
ever heard in my life what is this all
right it's donald cerrone and he was
telling a cave diving story and it's on
youtube and
when he did it like even though i knew
he was here
so i knew he was alive yeah he's
obviously alive he's sitting in front of
me telling me the story it's about him
but as he's telling me i'm so filled
with anxiety that i i i can hardly
breathe because he's doing an amazing
job of telling it and the and the story
is terrifying and then he's thinking
about getting back to his wife and his
kid yeah you know that's what he's
thinking about
and while he's trying to find his way
out he's like i am not going to [ __ ]
quit i'm going to get out and he finally
gets out
it's like yo
but he's like you want to talk about
he's a hardcore adrenaline junkie that's
what that is yeah i mean he's a
professional cage fighter he's had 48
fights in ufc yeah he jumps jet skis and
[ __ ] he's always doing nutty things